[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
all right let's go we'll be getting some
emotes any day now
yes yes any day now guild wars
okay let's go d4 this time let's go d4
let's play some main lines let's play
uh names this is called the nimzo indian
defense
now i will explain this after the game
properly
but i'm going to play a move which i
play as my main line that is the move f3
the idea behind this is very simple i
want to play e4
eric thanks for the sub now we want to
go a3 to chase the fish away
worrying that i will explain all of the
theory after the game basically you get
this structure
now what should you guys notice about
the structure what does the battle
revolve around the battle revolves
around one very specific thing
very specific thing it depends which way
he takes knight takes okay
is white going to make be able to play
e4
is white going to be able to play for
under the correct conditions
i can't play e4 now even if i
technically could i'm not developed
so every action that i undertake from
this point onwards is going to be
directed at preparing e4 as fast as
possible
and developing this bishop is not
essential to preparing e4 i need to
develop the king side
so that i can castle quickly so that i
don't have to keep my king in the center
when i do play four so let's let's see
what i do e3
where am i going to put this bishop
where am i going to put this bishop
d3 then i'm going to put the knight on
e2 i'm going to castle
and i'm going to at some point be ready
to play for this is the theoretical line
black has several ways that he can go
about
trying to stop e4 uh but
this is theory this line is not
considered to be black's best but even
magnus has played it before so
it's it's very much legitimate and um 92
castles
and i will explain afterward whether we
will be ready to play e4
well if c4 then bishop b2 we don't have
to worry about c4
c4 bishop c2 doesn't actually obstruct a
rookie 80 stops
it now where can this knight end up to
prepare e4
where can this knight go with the
express purpose of preparing e4 bingo
g3 okay so it's not he does play c4 but
here's the problem with the moves before
he takes the pressure off of the pawn on
d4
and can you guys see that now if i play
e4 i also have to deal with this pawn
becoming weaker
once he plays c4 the pawn on d4 is
better protected
so i can direct all of my attention at
preparing me for
it would be possible to play before here
but what do i need to do first
as a good russian school boy that i am
let's be patient
and let's castle well space isn't
important here space
is a sort of okay
transformational advantage
space is like money i'll explain
what i mean so finally we can consider
playing e4
but let's be good russian skill voice
and i guarantee you guys if we can
prepare this well
e4 is going to be a lot stronger so
let's play knight g3 first
why because ultimately the knight can go
to f5 in some positions
and there's nothing he can do to stop
before once we play e4
we're going to just steamroll him on the
king's side and i want you to watch very
carefully
how i go about doing that here we go
yeah so time it goes okay so how do we
do how do we do this
there is a very typical idea here i will
show you guys after this game a game in
which i
i applied this idea how do we make
something of
this pawn of these pawns
can anybody tell me yeah we just pushed
the pawns boom
locking this in and then boom boom now
we're not just doing this to win a piece
although he can't avoid that
even if this wasn't winning a piece this
would just be crushing you guys should
just kind of see that now bishop g5
is a good thought but he could play h6
and notice that the knight on g6 is
covering the h4 square
and the game is basically over so that's
how effective this line can be
if if black isn't very precise that's
why i really play that's why i like
playing and i've won a couple nice okay
so five is a good move
and here's the thing um what is the top
item on our wish list the top item on
our wish list is to eventually get our
pawn to f5
and the move on poissant comes to mind
but i actually am sound would be good
but i'm going to play well actually yan
poisson would be really good
because the good thing about amphison is
that if he recaptures
then we have f5 winning a piece the
problem without passant
it is emotionally hard for me to part
ways with my pawn sort of my pawn mass
but uh you have to transform your
advantage at some point
and you you can't cling to something
that's nice
sometimes you have to kill your darlings
as they say in literature yeah i'm
writing down notes to explain after the
game
kill your kill your darlings is a phrase
my english teacher used
to describe you know something you have
to do in writing
where sometimes you get very clingy
about a phrase that you think is good
and that actually holds you up in terms
of expressing your thoughts better
so we're just gonna like autopilot this
what do we do now
just bash it in and this is the good
thing
right our pieces look at how well
prepared they are to attack the king's
side
well queen g4 is tempting but actually
queen g4 is a really good move yeah
queen g4
is good but let's go f6 let's open up
yeah this is very violent terminology i
don't know where i i don't know why i'm
all of a sudden
said talking about the violently queen
g4 would be good
but um let's let's do let's do this
let's open up the mission
now let's figure out exactly what we
want to do queen g4 here i know it's
on a lot of people's minds but let's be
methodical if we go queen g4
he can play bishop g6 and he can stop
i will explain knight f6 we had bishop
g5 so
he can stop the bleeding on the g file
so
what we need to do is we need to find a
way to bring another piece into the
attack
and we need to circumvent his attack on
the g6
square his control of it there is a
different square that this pawn now
controls
and that is the g7 square i know you
guys are why the hell is
he taking well by taking on f6 he's
opening up the possibility of me pinning
him
remember how you decide whether a pin is
dangerous is there a pawn protecting the
pinned
piece notice that alliteration in this
case
there is no pawn protecting the pin
piece and so that pin is going to be
absolutely deadly we're just going to
pile up on this night
and we're going to win the night and
you're going to guys are going to see
piling up
all i'm doing is piling up in the night
winning the night transforming our
advantage up a piece in the end game the
game is over
that's it that's all i did let's bring
the rook into the game and defend the
rook
okay now knight f5 here doesn't work
because we lose control of our rook but
we want to get the knights five so we
need to move the rook first
where should we move the rook we can
also take on h7 that's a good move
but let's go rook d6 that's the most
active square for the rook
because if his rook moves away from e7
we can go to d7
everything i'm doing should be making
sense in terms of the attack
okay so now that's a good move if we
take it he takes back but we're going to
do that anyway because now we can take
d5
that was another reason i played rook d6
um
well we keep getting sub bombs
okay now let's just check again i want
to emphasize
that in the in this situation there are
so many ways to win these positions
sorry let me repeat though
okay so i wanted to repeat moves i
didn't want to lap to double get games
guild
and uh that was nice thank you and he
also watches my stream
so f3 the f3 is called the sameish
variation
and by the way yes it's it's the same
issue in both the king's indian
and in the nimzo indian friedrich samish
had a thing for the move f3
and let me tell you he introduced some
very serious lines into chess
oh i am kyle iron man 500 bits f3 was
first played
in the year uh let's see when it was
first played it was first played in the
year 18 i'm sorry in 1930
by rottenstein but he didn't play it
well boggle you off effin bubble you
above
max irva world champion played f3
samish actually i this is interesting
so samish actually never played f3 but
a3 is also the same as should often
transposes why i can go a3 first
and only play f3 later this is also the
sameish
and this samish actually
did play so he sort of played this but
i'm not sure why it's necessarily called
the same
okay now let's unpack what happened in
the game
i think that for black the move knight
takes d5 is better
because black immediately piles up on
the base of the pawn chain this is a
theoretical line i've also played games
here
i'm not going to delve into this but e
takes d5 is the old-school main line
now what should black do here black's
main line
is essentially to find a way to trade
the bishop who can tell me how black can
try to trade the bishop
why do you trade the bishop to make it
harder for white to prepare e4
because the bishop is the main
supervisor of that all operation
malcolm is on fire b6 and bishop a6
now you can say well no big deal i can
step aside but now look at how good
black's bishop is
and in a situation like this it's harder
to move the knight out
because of the pin so it becomes quite a
bit harder to prepare
before so in this situation you actually
don't do anything you just
castle and that's that leads to some
main light theory i'll show you guys the
game in the slide
so what are we so c4 is a mistake
because it takes the gas pedal off of
the d4 pawn
at least keeping that tension would have
made it harder for me to prepare for
and once we play e4 it's almost winning
for white because this
is just completely unstoppable um i
almost think this is losing i just don't
know what black can do about this
and let me show you guys a higher level
game where i actually did
something very very similar and beat a
very strong player with this line
now the game i'm about to show you it's
a little bit more complicated so i want
you guys to prepare for some more
a little bit more messiness than in this
game
okay so basically this game i played f3
and i'll talk about space's money when
we actually analyze
well so you can you guys can see r dot
cataloo 500 bits
you guys can see um what he's doing
here's knight g3 and now the move bishop
b2
and i want people to help me explain
this move why the hell
are we putting the bishop on a square
where it's literally
blocked in buried alive by these two
pawns exactly
malcolm have tucker is on fire today
i've noticed
you're on a roll loving the engagement
my friend
so basically we support 600 bits from
mine called iron man
400 500 600 here we go basically
it it protects d4 so if we imagine when
we do play e4
and i did uh you can see that in a
situation like this the pawn on d4
is uh is b is being very well protected
by the bishop and the bishop has a lot
of what fill in the blank
the bishop has a lot of blank link
using terminology that we uh that we
have formulated
potential energy bingo potential energy
all right bishop has a lot of potential
energy it's bad right now
but it's doing something really good
rook c8 rook 81
rookie 2 so i didn't play e4 yet and the
reason i didn't play e4
is because he takes and what super nasty
move
does black now have this is why patience
is so important
you have to always be attentive to why
your opponent does what they do
queen c2 so now laptop plays knight f8
e4 knight g6 threatening the fork
so i step away with my queen if we go e5
here he counter forks my king and
my queen and rock knight f4 we just go
rookie f2
and now watch what happens watch what
happens
[Music]
so basically this gets me these
incredible pawns the game went on
uh he didn't resign here but black is
lost uh and
it took me some finessing but eventually
i played e6
his king was weak i got the bishop to a
good square we went into an end game
i got my pawn to e7 mozart of cheese
thank you i won the other pawn
and he resigned here because i'm just
winning f7 and the pawns won me the game
that's pretty symbolic
essentially this is exactly what happens
here e takes f6
and f5 fg and now f6 why am i playing
this move
well the logical reason is to open up
the bishop but if knight takes f6 we go
bishop g5 and his knight is
busted also like you guys should look at
this position and it should be very
clear to everybody that white is
completely winning
i mean look at just look at the amount
of pieces that are in the attack
you shouldn't have to always worry about
exactly how you're going to make things
happen
um you should use your intuition here to
determine that
you're going to have something here i
mean black's position is just on its
last legs and we do the same thing we
did in the game
why is space like money so
money is something that society assigns
value to money has no inherent value i
can get out a one dollar bill or a 20
bill and somebody from a completely
different culture
would not necessarily understand its
value it's a piece of paper
and it we agree that it is value so you
can use it to buy stuff and that stuff
potentially has inherent value
um something that we can all agree is
valuable like a computer
most people nowadays can agree it's
valuable uh and don't nitpick you
understand what i'm saying space and
time
in chess tempi time and space is the
same
concept space has no inherent value
unless you make something of it
so just grabbing space to graph space
is sometimes good but it's only good in
so far as you can transform it
into some other advantage and uh some
people i think have a hard time with
this because
uh space advantage is actually one of
the most innocuous types of advantages
you can use it very well i'm never
particularly good with a big space
advantage
but you can also play when you're
cramped to the last two rows that's not
necessarily
a deal breaker to some positions okay
so just wanted to make that clear um i
would say when you get to extra material
that is closer to an inherent value kind
of thing
it's normally in any position an extra
piece has
immediate value toward winning the game
space needs to be transformed into
something before it literally wins you
the game
okay uh anyway so the rest of the game
was very simple
we um we win the piece here
and that's it we're up a piece and the
game is over so i really like the
same variation of the nimso and uh it's
black has other ways that he can play
against the c5 as possible here
that's probably black's most popular
line in the modern day
also he can drop his bishop back you can
that's the hyper modern approach you
could let white have a huge center
and then chip away at it with a move
like e5 that's another good line
so i don't want to bog ourselves down
with the theory but that was your
introduction to the samish if you're a
d4 player i would highly consider taking
this on
let's see how magnus went about
preventing this stuff
oh 300 bits thank you so much and it
never stops
thank you and c4 so
here's how anand prepares it he goes g4
he gets the pawn out there first
to fianchetto the bishop because this
bishop will otherwise have a hard time
developing
carlson goes for the queen side pressure
and you can see that anand
does manage to organize e4 that's how he
does it he puts the bishop on g2 instead
of d3
anand was better in this game carlson
won in the end it was a complicated game
we're not going to go into it right now
but um
but but a non digi 4 in the end so you
can see you found an alternate method
of doing it let's get one last game in
one last speeder in game
and let's go back to playing e5 so
knight f3 knight c6 and we have a four
knights defense
so there's many ways of playing against
the four knights
now one very topical line is to go
knight to d4 here
i'll explain this after the game okay so
white goes for the drawing line
yeah i was going to say the drawback of
this is that white has this line which
ends in mass liquidation so we have to
take his knight
he takes mine if i take on p2 he takes
the bishop and he develops a lot of his
pieces so we've got to take on f6
and um we get this very symmetrical
position two bishops each it's not a
draw
but it's equal so we gotta develop our
bishop
he's gonna castle now can we castle or
does this blunder upon on d7
can we castle or does this blunder upon
these we're getting a raid
oh my god don't tell me we're getting
another raid
by who we can why can we castle
why is bishop d7 on a move because of
rook d8
exactly guys very nice we pin him so we
got to notice these things bishop d3
look at this bishop on c5 very carefully
it's undefended
which means he's threatening queen h5 do
we need to stop queen h5 or could we
defend the bishop
and if so how what can we do zion pure
and hard thank you for the raid
sorry i might have a story d6 is exactly
right
good job guys d6 defense the bishop g6
defends against me
this is probably still theory and now
let's deploy the bishop now we got to be
careful about where we develop it
because
actually let's not develop let's let's
get the rook to an open file first
let's be a little bit more flexible now
we have to trade queens that oh okay
queen h or
wow this is still probably theory and i
think i got myself in some trouble here
i forgot about that move
um
[Music]
do you guys see why i'm in trouble
because bishop f6 is a big problem
so here's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
make a little envelope for the queen i'm
gonna go h5
and the idea of this move is to get the
queen to h6
uh at least my queen is in the game i am
weakening my king side that is true
but at least the queen is in the game um
i haven't lost to anybody who wasn't
using an engine yet but i will
ultimately and uh
you guys might be like well how do you
know that it's worth making the week now
a4 what is the threat
what should we do yeah so this threatens
b4 and a5
we need to create a hole for our bishop
let's do that with the move a6
yeah it's making the best of an
unfortunate situation you got to learn
how to do that if you want to be good
because a lot of people they blunder and
they get so dejected immediately they
don't realize that the situation isn't
as bad as they're making it out to be
so a5 would have weakened the b5 square
which is a very minor point but just
so you guys know the move a5 what we can
be found out
why am i not afraid of b4 i actually
want him to go before
because that would weaken the c3 plot
i'm trying to lure him
into creating weaknesses so that i can
somehow counterbalance
the fact that he has pressure on the
king's side if that makes sense
okay so rookie one let's get the bishop
out
um this should be six preserving the
rooks on the board that gives the game
a little bit more flavor we could have
also gone bishop d7 that might have even
been better
uh supporting the rockanita kind of
missed that move to be honest
but this is fine um
so let's see what he what he ends up
doing still a pretty dry position
not much going on um we have a nice
bishop bishop f6 queen h6 is fine for us
and um of course we want to play for a
win here that's just what i want to do
so let's see what he does maybe he over
presses
and um this is annoying no this line is
very annoying i forgot about it to be
honest
okay so what should we do he wants to
trade bishops we need to decide
whether we trade and if we are going to
trade we need to decide on what terms we
want to trade
so actually we are going to trade and
the basic reason is i get his queen out
of h4
where it was annoying me by preparing
bishop essex now we have an opportunity
we need to use this opportunity to try
to seize control of the e-file
the e-file is the main artery to his
position how do we do that
right because one rook defends the other
but we have the move rookie five the
rook gets onto a defended square
it's like a checkpoint and our idea is
to double hooks
now you guys might look at this and say
well wait a second he can go bishop f4 i
know people are thinking this
but if he goes bishop f4 then the rook
can reposition to f5
that does give up the e file that is
true but
it puts a lot of pressure on his bishop
and by extension on his pawn on f2 what
i'm trying to do here is unbalance the
position
trying to get some intrigue going some
tactics so that he has to calculate
now he has a decision to make which is a
good thing in blitz he's going to burn
some clock
decides to take of course we take with
the queen now this is on our
is under under our control
talking too fast what should we do now
where should we put our queen we have
several good options
several good options let's complete that
five thousand same idea as workout five
pressuring f2 now look at this bishop
what can you guys tell me about it
it's a what what what it's a type what
what
and what should we do here so we can
just drop our bishop back right he can't
take on c7 because
it's a type type
two undefended piece which means we need
to notice that bishop and start
calculating
tactics in relation to it uh that also
means the queen is tied down
and if we attack the queen it's going to
have a very very hard time keeping the
bishop protected which is why he drops
it back
now we need to start playing
aggressively here which often means
sacrificing something
so i have a very interesting idea in
mind what
yeah rookie 8 now we're sacrificing a
pawn in order to grab control of e file
but i have made a judgment call
the judgment call is that seizing
control of the file is so important
that it is actually worth giving up the
c7
over and potentially even more pawns i
also have a tactical idea after queen
takes c7 he's deciding whether to
capture i can see the wheels turning in
his head
okay now let me explain this idea
what is our top wish list item what
would be like the ideal scenario here
wait not rookie 2 because of rook f1 let
me let me kind of justify it
so the wishlist scenario is checkmate on
e1
we want to get the queen to e1 if we go
queen e4 we telegraph the pass
right he can go h3 so can we set up a
situation
where we can simultaneously threaten
checkmate in something else
the move is h4 now he has to take i
think
otherwise he loses f2 with main we get
the bishop on a type
one on defended square and then we fork
it by playing queen e4
there's complications there he can try
to defend the bishop and made against
at the same time but that creates other
weaknesses
then we threaten the bishop that's it
that's the whole logic this is not that
complicated
i think h4 is a really really strong
move that's what i saw when i sacked the
pawn
i'm sure there were other ideas here and
i think he probably has some sort of a
defensive resource
but we'll see if he finds something
right so bishop takes d6 don't forget
why we played queen f5 in the first
place
don't forget that we're x-raying that
pawn and he's paying the price for
that now that pawn is gonna be
unattended and if we take it we can then
get a rook or a queen to e1
that's a sexy move yeah i think he's
okay so i saw this too
and this is a very strong defensive idea
he wants to play hg
queen takes a7 that queen is guarding f2
so how do we need to
think about the situation well we need
to first of all we still have the idea
of bringing the queen t1
we cannot go queen e4 because he trades
queens
but um we can uh what can we do here
what what are our options
well we can play queen take c2 but then
he takes a7 so what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna go queen e6
i'm gonna go queen e6 i'll explain type
1 and type 2 guys but you have to let me
you have to understand that there are
people joining the stream or new
oh my god he defended he found a way to
defend amazing because rookie 70s got a
check
all right i'm gonna have to take okay
this is bad
but there's the good news the good news
is his king is still very weak
uh which gives us hope but in general uh
we're fighting for a draw now we're
gonna
snag off one of his pawns he actually
found a brilliant offensive idea here
we'll talk about it after the game for
now we have to defend we're going to be
down upon at the end of the day
which is fine because his king is still
quite weak
our pieces are very active and we're
only down upon and he's got a weak pawn
in a4 but
i don't want to trade queens if we want
to keep winning chances alive
we need to activate our pieces asap how
do we do that how do we activate our
work where do we put it
what is so brilliant about rook well
nuke i think it's a nice move
i'm sorry if it was very obvious so
first of all
let's yeah rookie five is correct okay
now we're gonna lift the rook up we're
gonna lift the rook up thread checkmate
okay we're going to thread and check and
now what what do we do now he's weak in
the diagonal how do we exploit it
quickly
help me out heroes how do we exploit it
boom
and he has to go f3 but now let's snag
the pawn
intermediate move snagging the pawn
making sure the material is equal
now let's go in for the let's go in for
the kill queenie two threats checkmate
it threatens a lot of checks we're gonna
take here
we're threatening checkmate again king
h7 i don't see a defense and he's lost
he has to give the queen up boom goes
the dynamite thank you brett toad for
the prime
so we won in the end but that was a very
back and forth game
but it was a really interesting game so
in the four nights defense knight e4
so type 1 and type 2 undefended pieces
guys type 1 undefended by anything type
2 defended only by exactly one piece
so he plays this line with e5 one of the
main lines here is bishop back to c4 you
don't really want to give that bishop up
but he goes for this very drawish line
where there's a lot of trades
we develop our bishop castle castle
bishop d3
and somewhere here i made a mistake i'm
not sure exactly what the theory is here
but um i think it's somewhere here
ah so i think here i shouldn't have
played queen uh actually this is fine
but hero g6 was a mistake
g6 was a mistake what should i have done
instead
h6 is correct and um we stop bishop g5
and we defend against mate i just didn't
realize that the holes i'm making on the
king's side
are significant i forgot about this move
and actually this move happens whatever
we do i can't
defend against bishop g5 which brings us
into a very nasty situation
now if we just pretend that nothing's
happening he gets the bishop here
and he clamps down and look how passive
this is he can bring the rook to e1
he's got lobster pincer ideas i didn't
want to allow this to happen
now one second
okay so basically
if we go rookie six to try to defend
against
the f6 square then bishop c4
okay and uh we have to bring our rook
back so we have to allow it but i did
that by
setting up the h6 square for our queen
so we at least keep some pieces active
a4 a6
again a5 would have weakened the square
and also i wanted to lure him into going
b4 so that he weakens these squares
right
so bishop b6 takes and rookie five now
the battle revolves around the e
file battle starts revolving around the
evo who can get control of the e file
if he goes bishop f4 i can reposition to
the file you have to be flexible
he takes and in this position i have a
choice
i can maintain my control over the
e-file how can i do that if i wanted to
maintain control
over the e-fund where should i put my
queen
yeah i should have put it not only to
have learners to queen
not queen e6 guys because then he takes
and he gets control of the
but on e7 you shouldn't be afraid to
make retreating moves
at various wins then i can go but i
wanted to play more adventurously so we
got queen f5
uh trying to exploit the weakness that i
have to also i'm attacking c2
okay so this is where i made the
judgment call
to sacrifice on c7 and in retrospect
that might have been wrong
so i could have gone c6 here and
defended it he cannot take on d6 because
f2 drops
perhaps i could have done that um and
instead i decided to stack the pawn so
here let me unpack for a second
the idea of h4 so h4
basically tries to lure his bishop onto
an undefended
square if we go queen e4 immediately
sorry
that is what i compare this to is
telegraphing the pass in basketball
that's like holding the basketball over
your head
and looking at your the person you're
going to pass the ball to well the
opposing team is going to see
in football that's the thing is going to
see who you want to pass it to
and he can prevent the man with h4
so instead we lure the bishop onto h4
and then we're going to go with 84 and
this creates a fork
against these two pieces if he goes g3
he weakens his control over f2 we can
slide our queen into f3
okay um and i think this creates very
very big threat i'm not sure this is
winning
it creates big threats against skin
black has a pretty strong attack
uh donations we got a donation
i'm sorry i i might have missed it oh
one dollar from bracket boy
thank you so much sorry i missed that
donut one dollar from bracket boy
um but yeah i try to read donations when
possible because i have the alerts on
okay so queen f3 would have been very
strong but instead what did i blunder
queen takes b7 is super strong fable
thank you for the spawn
if hg he goes queen takes a7 and
simultaneously defends f2 this is what i
missed
so i decided to go queen e6 sticking to
my old idea but now rook f1 is super
strong
he gets the rook onto f1 so that this
move is no longer check
and he doesn't have to take my queen he
can just take the bishop for example
okay and what i decided to do and at the
end of the day uh
i'm in trouble at the end of the damn
troll because if i now move my bishop
back
maybe this was correct actually but then
he plays bishop takes h4 and i can no
longer
get the queen onto e4 the great thing
about this move isn't that it only takes
the pawn it also brings the e4 square
under control
so look for these kinds of intermediate
moves
okay so rock f1 i acquiesced to a bad
position but at least black has peace
activity and
return for the plot i think winning this
would be really hard i actually think
black's drawing chances outweigh white's
winning chances
activating the rook and here he made a
very big mistake how should he have
defended
the pawn on g2 without weakening his
king side not a not a pretty move
but i think that g3 set him up for
trouble
so there's two possibilities here that
would have both been better than g3
the first is f3 which at least is not as
bad but i think windage would be the
most circumspect
it is true i can take his pawns now but
it's a draw g3 set him up for trouble
because now he has all of these
weaknesses and this is so hard to defend
in a blitz game
i'm pretty sure you can still make a
draw but in a blitz game these kinds of
positions are super hard to defend
because it's a
it's a king weakness okay
um so that basically won the game very
back and forth very well played by my
opponent
which is awesome my opponents are
putting up a great fight and we're
almost at 2200 so
we're 300 points away from the
conclusion of the speed run
it's been an amazing ride so far but i
think i'm going to stop for today here
i've got a lot of work to do guys
unless there's serious objections um i
think this might be a good good time to
pause for the evening rent crow thank
you for the prom skis
thank you for the prime i see people
trying to bribe me 245 from luki
there's objections objection your honor
yeah just give me a second let me let me
sip some water
yeah the thing is guys this does take a
lot of energy you know i'm trying to
really
every move i'm trying to engage in the
position and uh
oh here come the brevis happy pineapple
double oh seven five gifted
fair enough okay we'll do an encore one
more
we'll do one more five three six one
that's a great number
we'll do one last one guys uh just give
me a second to compose myself
yeah you're very welcome
thanks happy pineapple double007 gifted
five
appreciate it very much okay
um oh my god here we go to seeb's
matching it five gifted as well
this man is on a tear today tess seems
thank you for the five gifted
um no i'm not trying to elicit people's
like sympathy i i really enjoy this this
is a lot of fun but
uh this is awesome okay um
so let's go into the pool i think i'm
good now
have a little coffee compose myself get
my wish back
holy smokes that's awesome julian
all right um let's play
one last one guys
hey guys this is john
okay
now everything is going to be up on
youtube oh thank you uh mad knocks my
man
oh i might have missed it sorry madness
i'm really sorry
i'll look back at it okay so let's go
back to the sit sil actually let's play
malachi now so a lot of people wanted me
to play a jeep ribbik another sub
wanted me to play an alakan i will
respond now this position
we can take the knight the issue with
taking the knight
is that he can take with the d-pawn and
he accelerates the pace of his
development so what we're going to do is
we're going to drop the knight back to
b6
and we're going to come we're going to
control the center ourselves either with
d5
but the alakan is what kind of opening
fill in the blank now we need to go 85
to stop
it from doing that and who can summarize
to me
the sort of fundamental logic behind
these types of openings it's called a
hyper modern opening
the hyper modern it's not about it's not
about controlling
the center with as many pawns as
possible it's about
making sure that you can attack your
opponent's center of the species you
want to provoke your opponent
into controlling a lot of the center
julian berman thank you so we can't go
d6 that was the point of his move
now what should we do unless he doesn't
control the center then we can actually
finally you know we can we can make a
claim to the center but let's actually
go
so knight c6 he would have d4 and i want
to keep the c file
let's go let's actually go c6 let's get
the bishop out
and and let's go d5 so our opponent has
decided not to control the center at all
so we have nothing to attack so again
flexibility flexibility flexibility
uh in any opening you want to have the
idea of changing your strategy if your
opponent does something weird
you can't put your head down and always
do the same thing every time people get
into trouble because of that
how should we go about developing this
bishop without obstructing this bishop
if we play bishop g4 he can start
chasing our bishop around yeah we
fianchetto
and we attack e5 good job bishop g4 he
would play h3
that would be kind of an empty pen
okay so he's gonna fianchetto his own
bishop let's let's castle let's complete
our development
now let's take a look at this knight
let's take a good hard look ooh h4 okay
now action on the flanks as we know from
a very important principle
is oftentimes met with action in the
center
what does that mean how do we ensure
active development of this knight bingo
c5 knight c6 now why are we putting the
knight on c6
it's more active if we go knight d7 we
block our own bishop
and we potentially can consider c4
pressuring his position that doesn't
trap the bishop
because he can play bc and get the
bishop to e4 so we need to be careful
about that
one second
okay so knight c6 attacking e5
knight c6 attacking e5 and then
uh if knight f3 what now are we going to
do
thanks again guys for all of the support
and the engagement most of
everybody being engaged makes this
better and uh yeah this is awesome
okay so bishop g4 is correct now we pin
him
because the spin is a very specific
purpose we are trying to win the e5 pawn
now let's unpack the situation we have
many good moves here there's many
approaches to the position
he cannot push the pawn because his
bishop is type 1
how do we apply pressure on this pawn
how do we apply pressure on the c5 and
that would be the most consistent
strategy
we can also go night before we can
consider c4 there's a lot of possible
moves here but let's keep things
consistent with our general approach
which is to win that central pawn thank
you dovah 7.
and you know this is annoying because
it's hard to defend against consistency
appreciated nova 7 priming
uh but we shouldn't necessarily play
bishop f3 bishop e5 so
we can win the pawn we can play bishop
f3 and bishop e5
but there's a little bit of complication
there so let's let's do it
we also have to be careful our king's
side okay which way should we take the
pawn
very very important which way should we
take the pawn
so not bishop takes because of knight
takes d5 we should take it with a knight
to attack his queen
if we had taken with a bishop we would
have allowed knight takes d5
now we attack a screen and believe it or
not there's something i missed here
and yes i do miss tactical details
occasionally
he actually can still play knight takes
d5 because it attacks my queen
uh and that leads to a very interesting
and very complicated situation i think
he's calculating this
i i will still be better uh because we
will be able to move our queen away
and force him to take his night to take
my night with his bishop
weakening his own king i'll explain that
situation if he takes on d5
that's not an easy thing to see because
a lot of people would automatically
bring their queen back or take on e5
which would be even worse because we
could checkmate him
but we will see if he finds it
yeah so you just got to be attentive to
this stuff and that's a mentality that's
a mindset in my opinion
that's a mindset of not taking things
for granted and always questioning your
opponent
he doesn't now what's the issue the
issue is twitch let's go thank you
divina rating 51 appreciate it
we're attacking we're doing the speedrun
attacking the queen and attacking the
knight does that make sense guys if he
moves the queen we take his knight
if he moves his knight we take the queen
so he has to take on e5 now which way do
we take i just gave it away
doesn't queen take c5 blunder knight
takes b6
same mentality we don't take things for
granted we don't assume anything about
what we have to do we consider all the
options
no because a checkmate he's got to drop
his knight back amazingly
he holds on now we have an opportunity
we need to strike we need to strike
while the iron is high
what does it mean to strike in such a
situation couple of things to notice
number one knight is tied down if the
knight moves he gets checkmated
boom we need to open up files for our
pieces and notice that i'm making this
move without calculating
i just want to open stuff off it's only
sacrificing a pawn
it's not a big deal and we're opening up
the c file
and if he takes of the pawn then we can
actually play knight takes a4
oh that is a very bad one that is panic
but let's be logical in our thinking the
knight is hanging
can we defend the knight with tempo and
then win the bishop yeah simple move
rook a b8
queen has to move and then cd so he
might trade queens here but we're gonna
be up a piece
once again excuse me transforming our
advantage
yeah that was panic but he was already
in big trouble
okay so he's creative but uh but this is
not good enough so actually here if we
want to play for maximum
what he's allowed us to do is an
opportunity let's not rush with taking
the queen
i know a lot of people want to take and
take but we can just move our queen to
c5 because the situation remains
his queen is attacked and now in
addition to everything else
our queen has access to the a3 square in
fact
i'm telling you guys we might not even
need to take the bishop we might
checkmate him even without that
that was impulsive but it was also
panicky and i understand why
so well just in case i'm putting out one
video today my editor is working very
hard
as you know i have a lot of things i'm
up i'm up to so it takes time
now actually who with a keen tactical
eye
can find the wind here forget the bishop
we have a better move
remember that you're that his knight is
tied down
well we are speedrunning the editing
believe it or not it's harder than it
seems
bingo good job guys knight is tied down
pawn is pinned
queen be too threatened he's made it in
one
simple effective and strong and we
didn't even need to take the bishop
that is why you don't rush because you
find things out about the position
when you take your time when you look at
the whole board all right
good game we're gonna go over the game
then we're gonna pause for today
i know a lot of people people like to
bribe me but i
you know this is gonna be the last game
i still appreciate the bribes
so okay
again make it look easy well i mean
that's the point hey harry shadow gets
the sale
all right so 21.99 i know what people
thinking the alakan now knight c3 is a
move
but here bishop b5 was weird i mean
he starts to he starts to just move his
pieces around he should have gone d4
and then we go d6 and this is sort of a
main line of the allagan
wolfie encounter the bishop we will
attack e5 we're trying to get him to
take on d6
to give us more freedom white is
slightly better in these positions but
it's interesting we've played this
before
so bishop d3 is a bad move for the very
elementary reason
that it obstructs the bun i think he
already at this point had the idea of
fianchettoing but it's just
janky d5 he could have unpassanted us
but then we would have taken and
developed our bishop to e7 and then
castle
black is completely fine i think he
should have done that though
he goes 92 and now g6 fianchetto in the
bishop there should be two
castles h4 he starts attacking so the
principle dictates that
uh when our opponent is playing on the
flank the g moses another thousand thank
you
appreciate it when our opponent plays on
the flank he takes his attention off
from the center so we should do
something in the center
um and i can show you guys a lot of
instantiations of
this principle in complicated positions
this is something that applies at a
grand master level
um i have a couple favorite games that
really illustrate this concept
um and sometimes cole drobo think for
the prime
you know sometimes playing the center
involves doing something a little crazy
sometimes striking in the center
involves sacrificing
so let me show you guys very quickly
this is complicated but i won't delve
into any of the complications
uh korchnoy against luke mcshane british
player
very strong and this position court
schneider is h4
so luke mcshane takes on d5 and what
seemingly crazy move
do you think he plays by the way i want
you guys to notice the x-ray
that is going to be important boom e5
ripping open the position and the reason
he does that is that white is not
developed enough on the king side
now the point is if f takes c5 and
knight c6 is a beautiful move
using the x-ray and if bishop takes b6
then black has a humongous attack in
return for the peace
and um this is just scratching and if
bishop takes c5
then we have that e-file machine didn't
end up playing rookie 8 but now we use
the bishop to
accelerate our development and black
gets a big initiative mcshane won the
game
so there's there's there's many details
there but i just wanted to show you guys
this
does actually is is applicable the grand
master level very much so
um so remember that so c5 now knight f4
i think is a very expensive waste of
time you should have probably gone h5
but now he gets in big trouble because
his e5 pawn is indefensible we pressure
it
now we play bishop takes f3 and bit
knight takes e5 if bishop takes e5
he plays knight takes d5 some of you
might think oh wait a minute we fork his
king a knight
but he can just drop the knight back
it's very important for us to keep the
bishop
because this bishop is the main attacker
as you guys saw in the game
965 good job by my opponent but it
doesn't actually really help
because of this and now c4 opening up
the position
if b takes c4 what would we have done
well i understand his panic because he's
on the cusp of getting checkmated yeah
knight a4
is very simple so he plays bish queen b7
but if bishop takes c4
then we'd go knight c4 and we could go
queen c5 where we go rook cnn there's a
lot of moves here that
end up with the same results and uh this
is just pretty crushing so
he goes queen takes b7 and after rook
ab8
f4 queen c5 we don't even need to play
rook takes b7 and cd
so this is just winning queen a3 knight
takes a4
and queen a1 is checkmate and um
that's just a very simple attack we
didn't even have to take the bishop
so this is just winning yeah 1pm
tomorrow bullet championship
so that basically was again it was the
speedrun we're almost at 2200.